turquía niega ser la responsable del
atentado y el bombardeo que ayer acabó
con la vida de 9 personas 9 civiles en
el norte de irak e hirió a otros 24 en
el norte de irak una zona turística
donde
civiles unos 200 estaban veraneando de
estar las altas temperaturas
el gobierno de hecho culpa directamente
turquía y asegura que turquía viola
constantemente la soberanía territorial
medirá no sólo con este bombardeo que
supuestamente reza dos días sino también
las operaciones constantes que realiza
turquía en el norte de irak como también
en órdenes iría en contra de la
guerrilla puro turca del pkk esta
guerrilla lleva en guerra en contra de
turquía desde la década de los 80 en un
conflicto que ha muerto
con 40.000 personas tanto a manos de
operaciones militares turcas como
también en operaciones de este tipo
en la que el general está en el norte de
irak y es donde ahora mismo está
realizando turquía una ofensiva militar
desde abril a consulado sobre el terreno
y también con bombarderos y artillería
turquía sin embargo niega completamente
ser la que ayer mató a nueve civiles en
la ciudad dedujo que ellos dicen que el
atentado y el ataque bombardeo fue causa
hecho por el pkk en una especie de falsa
bandera para culpar a turquía en un
momento en el que turquía amenaza con
realizar otra operación militar no sólo
en el norte de irak sino también en el
norte de siria contra las milicias
aliadas del pkk en el norte si das lugar
a la comunidad internacional para que
acepten a otra ofensiva militar turca en
esa región y de hecho fue lo que habló
hace solo dos días en teherán con el
presidente iraní ebrahim raisi y con el
presidente de ruso vladimir putin